SHAWN: OK.
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to the recitation
section of 10.213.
This is the agenda for today.
So first of all, we
will review the concept
of the physical
state of a substance.
And secondly, we're going to
talk about phase diagramming.
First of all, the
physical state is a state
that a molecule can
exist in reality.
So take water as an example.
Water can exist as
gas, liquid, and--
STUDENTS: Solid.
SHAWN: Solid.
Correct.
So a phase diagram is a tool
for engineers or scientists
to interpret or very easily
identify the physical state
at a certain temperature
and pressure.
So we have this diagram.
And on the horizontal
axis is temperature,
with a unit of Celsius.
And on the vertical
axis, we have pressure,
with a unit of pascals.
OK?
As we just talked about, we have
three different states of water
exist in this diagram.
At high temperature-- this is
the high-temperature phase--
low pressure, water
will exist as--
STUDENTS: Gas.
SHAWN: Correct.
So this is the gas state.
And at low temperature, high
pressure, what do we exist as?
STUDENTS: Solid.
SHAWN: Solid?
Great.
And at moderate
temperature and pressure,
water will exist as liquid.
That's what we usually
see in reality.
And there are a lot of--
there are some-- sorry.
Some of the components
in this phase
diagram you have to identify
the physical state of the matter
and also when they transform
from one state to another.
So we have three
different lines here.
So each line represents
a certain condition
that two phases can coexist.
So for example, at 100 Celsius
and 101.325 kilopascals-- so
at this specific
pressure and temperature,
water can exist as gas
and liquid simultaneously.
So far, so clear?
OK.
And there's an intersecting
point of these three lines.
This intersecting point
is called a triple point.
At this triple point, we
have three phases coexist.
So solid, liquid, and gas can
exist at this specific pressure
and temperature.
OK.
So now there's a question.
Supposedly you're on
the mountain of Himalaya
and then you know
the pressure is
slightly lower than
1 atmosphere, which
is less than 1.1 kilopascal.
My question is, is the water
going to boil at 100 Celsius?
Or is it going to boil
below or above 100 Celsius?
Anyone that volunteer a guess?
Melissa?
STUDENTS: It would
be below 100 Celsius.
SHAWN: OK.
Why?
STUDENTS: Because if
you're at a lower pressure,
you'll intersect the coexistence
line between liquid and gas
at a lower temperature.
SHAWN: Correct.
Excellent.
Does anyone follow her?
OK.
Great.
So let me just wrap
up today's lesson.
We first reviewed the
physical state of water.
Water can exist as
liquid, solid, and gas
depending on the
temperature and pressure.
And then we drew the
phase diagram of water.
And there are three
different elements there,
which you'll remember.
First, in each space, you
have the phase of water.
And then we have the coexisting
lines, which is the lines
that water can exist
as two different phases
simultaneously.
And then we have
the triple point,
where three different
phases can coexist.
OK.
Any questions for today?
So this is for today.
Next time, we will talk about
phase diagrams of a mixture.
For example, if you add sodium
chloride, which is salt,
in water, how does the phase
diagram of water change?
If you want to know
that, definitely
come to our next
recitation section.
Thank you.